well hi everybody uh it's a great
opportunity to welcome you
here today wherever you are in the uh
in the symposium this is the agilent
science and technology symposium
uh one that we're very excited uh to
bring you
we've got a lot in store for you
opportunity for you to
navigate the site and to have some
interaction with our
uh people uh some networking and
collaboration opportunities so again
really an honor to be here
i'm the vice president for south asia
pacific
japan and korea and clearly really
excited to bring you
a lot of new innovations some
conversation and discussion
and uh really good to see the many
people who have joined us
and continuing to support and understand
more about what agilent
can help you with in your activities
with your own customers
just to really uh emphasize and
don't need to sort of go through it uh
too uh deeply but uh code 19 has
impacted us all across the markets and
uh
no different to what you're facing and
we're facing on a daily basis
but certainly i wanted to have a shout
out to all our engineers and i'm sure
those of you across the
uh the the community have seen the the
great work that our people are doing we
continue to
focus on the safety and well-being of
our people particularly our frontline
people and our customers so we're
engaging well with our customers
agilent is open for business we've we've
moved our whole organization to to be
safe and really focused on ensuring that
our customers are
we're there for our customers and
helping them to
achieve their outcomes uh and really
learning about the new way of work
and the way we're supporting and
continuing to understand
how we can help our customers our
support continues to be
unwavering and we thank all our
customers to to really uh be patient
and understand how further we can help
them and
really get through this together but um
in terms of some of the activities that
we've been doing and
some of the virtual online
collaborations we've been undertaking
one of the most exciting
parts of being helping our customers
preparing labs for
shutdown and reopening in fact it's
probably one of our
most well attended seminars
and really wanted to sort of just uh end
up my introduction
by reminding everyone of our wonderful
services crosslab asset monitoring
services these are services that can
help to increase visibility and access
to all sorts of lab operating data
financial clarity as well as flexibility
we find that these services are becoming
a lot more
possible and a lot more in demand as
well as
just connecting digitally with the lab
and so simple things like our smart
alerts
and the remote learning opportunities
that we have here at agilent
through our many many mediums so please
uh connect with our people through the
symposium or your account manager
wherever you are in the world
and again my my honor is to welcome you
here
and to kick off this symposium and
please continue to
give us your feedback through the survey
thank you very much
welcome everyone i'm susie valdez and i
will be your moderator for this
event thank you for joining us for our
first presentation
today titled innovation for quantitation
with agilent's
triple quadrupole lc ms portfolio
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
patrick batune
product manager of lcms triple
quadrupole
ion sources nitrogen generators and
software systems
at agilent technologies for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the tab
at the top of your screen if you have
any questions
during the presentation we encourage you
to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following the presentation please again
welcome
dr patrick patoon i will now turn the
presentation
over to him welcome sir
greetings everyone and hope you're doing
well these days
this talk is to be a quick overview of
agilent's triple quadrupole lcms
portfolio
as the product manager for this
portfolio i'd like to show you
some of my favorite highlights and
things i'd like to point out
although agilent has been involved in
the mass spectrometry field for a long
time
in regards to gcms you'd be surprised to
find out that our first triple quadruple
lcms launch
was in 2006 with the g6410
this was then followed up in the
proceeding years
with the launch of other models within
that decade such as the 6420 which is
not shown
but the 6430 and the 6460.
a major breakthrough was made at the
start of the decade by
adding an innovative new component which
is the dual stacked ring ion funnel
and this feature dramatically pushed
instrument detection limits
lower and lower additionally instead of
a linear design
the 90 degree turn in the ion optics
rail
was included as a way to reduce noise
from the fragmentation process
as we move into the 20 teens two related
models to the 6490 were launched
expanding on its capability which is the
6495a
with an extended mass range and also by
creating a version of this instrument
without an ifunnel resulting in an
incredible workhorse instrument
we call the 6470a many of which are
still used today
in addition to the launch of a 6495b
model not shown but launched in 2017
2017 and 2018 brought along a new era of
mass spectrometer instrumentation
with the triple quadrupole lcms this was
a disruptively miniaturized platform
with onboard instrument intelligence and
diagnostics
and based on the hardware inside we were
able to retain the performance
of the 6460 within this box
last year at asms we launched the 6495c
with a completely redesigned ifunnel
drastically improving
measurement precision and performance
for methods containing hundreds of mrams
within the method additionally
we've added vac shield as it was a
popular feature for multivo that allowed
users to carry out maintenance quickly
and easily
lastly this year at asms 2020
for the asms 2020 reboot event
we're launching an updated version of
the highly popular workhorse instrument
the 6470b this retains many of the
performance characteristics of the 6470a
but updated for today's problems with
the addition of that shield
so as we move along into the future
ultimately our aim is to enable
our users to do good science driving us
to develop new features
technologies and workflows to keep up
with customers ever-evolving needs
so before i go over the current triple
quadruple lcms portfolio
and hardware details i'm happy to
announce that for the
asms 2020 reboot we're launching a new
instrument called the 6470b triple
quadruple lcms system
the 6470b triple quadruple lcms
is the latest version of our trusted
workhorse on the 6470 platform
leveraging much of the technology that
made this platform successful
you can expect the 6470b to be just as
trusted
rugged and versatile with the added
enhancement of vaxshield to maximize
instrument uptime
and improve ease of maintenance
with that agilent's triple quadrupole
lcms portfolio
contains only three base products
the first product is the altivo which
was designed to be a routine workhorse
instrument
focusing on ease of use instrument
intelligence
and serviceability in addition to its
most distinguishing feature
its size and form factor
next up is the 6495c triple quadrupole
lcms
our ultra high performance instrument
built to tackle the most demanding
routine and research
applications each technological
component
has been built to extract the greatest
number of ions
for advanced applications without
complicating the instrument control
this allows researchers to focus on
scientific inquiries
rather than instrumentation problems
and last but definitely not least
sandwiched between the two models
is the 6470 triple quadrupole lcms
our most popular lcms triple quadrupole
to date
as it provides the ruggedness robustness
and ease of use from the ultivo while
maintaining many
of the research-enabled characteristics
of the 6495c
each instrument was built to focus on
solving different
aspects of customer problems while
maintaining consistency and cohesiveness
throughout
when jumping from instrument to
instrument within our portfolio
we've put a lot of effort so users can
feel confident
that they know how to run each
instrument they're operating with the
same familiarity
yet there's a distinct and incomparable
uniqueness
each model provides an important and
distinguishing feature of agilent's
triple quadrupole lcms portfolio
is the fact that all three instruments
in our current lineup
are vac shield enabled this unified
feature allows users to perform common
usage-based ion-injector capillary
maintenance
quickly and efficiently with minimal
downtime
this feature works by allowing the user
to remove the ion injector capillary
without venting the system as the
capillary is drawn out
a sealing mechanism is automatically
triggered maintaining the instrument's
optimal high vac pressure
and what's unique about this mechanism
is the introduction of an
intentional leak as if the capillary
were in place
this design prevents back flushing of
oil and contaminants
prevents turbulent gas events from
influencing the instrument's
equilibrated temperatures
to really point out the implications of
this feature users who implement ion
injector capillary cleaning
in their routine maintenance often
expect to spend
about six hours or more to do so this is
because they normally have to allow the
instrument to cool down
properly break vacuum carry out their
maintenance
then re-equilibrate the system again
before carrying out
a new check tune or auto-tune
instead users can simply slide out the
ion injector capillary
do their required maintenance then check
tune or auto-tune immediately after
this takes about 30 minutes to an hour
and sometimes even faster with ultivo
and since users no longer have to wait
a number of hours to pump down and
re-equilibrate the system
they can expect to be done in a very
short amount of time
for a little bit of history vac shield
was first pioneered on ultivo
added in 2019 to the 6495c
and now in 2020 with the launch of the
6470b
another common feature shared throughout
the triple quadrupole lcms portfolio
is the use of agilent jet stream
ionization
or ajs for short as the default ion
source configuration for users
we chose this because it provides users
a brighter ion response
due to the application of superheated
nitrogen sheath gas
and a nozzle voltage controller to have
greater influence
over the spray shape and the ion
sampling regions
to really demonstrate the effect of
superheated nitrogen gas
on ion sampling the image shown is
running in standard electrospray
conditions
after sheath gas superheating is enabled
the spray cone is much more focused
and less visible implying that more
liquid droplets have been desolvated
bringing more ions into the mass
spectrometer
because more ions have been desolvated
into the gas phase
greater ion flux is observed resulting
in greater analytical sensitivity
and allowing customers to achieve lower
limits of detection
than standard esi
however regardless of the applications
users wish to perform
we have a nice portfolio of available
ion sources to utilize
based on the electrospray mechanism or
based on the apci mechanism in addition
to
the ion source interfaces for capillary
electrophoresis
or nano flow hplc
as we go into the actual guts of the
instrument one surprising thing to note
is that the 6470b and the 6495c triple
quadruple lcms systems
are built upon a common ion optics
platform
this means that they share many
performance characteristics to one
another
especially in terms of signal stability
robustness versatility
for different routine and research
applications and the technical capacity
to get the job done
on this common ion optics platform it's
comprised of an octopus ion guide
to allow transmission of ions over a
wide effective m over z
range an rf only brew breaker
pre-filter for the pre-focusing of ions
into the quad
defeating the fringe field effects for
higher analytical sensitivity
of course we utilize hyperbolic quads
for efficient
mass selection they're also heated to
maintain
signal stability and prevent mass
calibration errors
a hexapole collision cell which also has
an extended mass transmission range
but is curved and tapered so that we can
prevent neutrals
that are produced after collision from
hitting the detector
while the taper helps refocus and
collimate the ions
for transmission into ms2
and lastly an advanced detector system
comprised of an adjustable
up to 20 kv high energy dinode system
used to launch particles towards an
electron multiplier horn
over the past decade since we have
launched the first instrument models on
this platform
we've iterated and improved
year-over-year to provide
the most reliable and sensitive lcms
systems to our users
one of the nice things we found with
this inoptics platform
on the 6470b and 6495c
is that users really appreciate the
ability to analyze ions
over an extremely wide m over z range
not only could users analyze and
quantitate the bread and butter small
molecules like pesticides
metabolites pharmaceuticals it's also
possible to analyze larger ions such as
peptides oligonucleotides carbohydrates
and synthetic polymers the example shown
here is just a demonstration
of our esil calibration ions throughout
the mass range
showing good performance throughout
additionally we always talk about the
robustness and stability of this ion
optics rail for these instruments
so here's some data to prove it this was
carried out
using our rapid fire system for sample
delivery and in this case
we've carried out 10 000 injections of
pharmaceuticals
spiked into pork plasma this is done
non-stop with no cleaning or tuning
when plotting the chromatographic peak
ratios with their isotopically labeled
standards
signal percent rsds were less than 10
percent
this demonstration was carried out on
the 6470a version of this model
however the iron optics rail was was
retained
with what we have today
so between the 6470 and the 6495
what's different i mentioned earlier
that the iron optics rail is shared
between these two instruments
but notice the protruding area after the
ion source
this houses what's called and what we
refer to as the eye funnel
made up of two stacked ring iron guides
this allows users to excel in the most
rigorous analytical conditions
by achieving incredibly low limits of
detection
and instrument detection limits this
allows users to obtain high measure
print precision
at standard concentrations for greater
detection confidence
this instrument is able to achieve the
lowest levels of analytical sensitivity
because we've extensively considered
what happens
as ions are introduced into the mass
spectrometer
as droplets get desolvated ions entered
the instrument as a diffuse cloud
influenced by electronic forces
to capture as much of the ion cloud as
possible the first stage of the ion
funnel captures stray ions
and collimates it back into the beam the
second stage
further focuses the ion beam for
transfer to the ion guide
i mean the end result is a greater
number of ions flowing into the
instrument
as a demonstration consider a standard
checkout experiment one picogram over
serpentine column
the chromatographic peak shape is very
nice signal is confidently detected
but it essentially tells us nothing of
the analytical sensitivity of the
instrument
because we can't see the noise
instead one femtogram of recirpine on
column is injected
which is a thousand times less giving us
a better sense of the baseline noise
and the rough magnitude of concentration
levels users
can expect to successfully detect
without issue
one interesting thing is that to
guarantee the analytical sensitivity and
performance of this instrument
this exact experiment is demonstrated at
every customer installation
where we expect to observe and measure
an instrument detection limit value of
less than 0.65
phantograms of a serpentine on column
and this is specified as the best idl
specification on the market
the last triple quadruple lcms hardware
platform in our portfolio
is the altivo triple quadruple lcms
which was a disruptive product to the
industry
many of the hardware components were
re-engineered
to ensure that it had a small form
factor
however despite its size the performance
of this
instrument is uncompromising as it was
intended to be a continuation
of the legacy workhorse instrument the
6460
with the same specifications instrument
sensitivity
and robustness with any improvements
that we can fit in
horizontally the altivo is roughly three
times smaller than the 6460
giving users access to precious lab
space for other tasks like sample
staging
or for even fitting more instruments
into a smaller space
additionally the altivo was designed to
be stackable
by seamlessly incorporating into the
hplc stack
at the base and when incorporated
with the right furniture such as the
flex bench ms
the altivo is completely unified as a
mobile platform
this allows some users to bring in and
out a mass spectrometer
whenever it's needed
oftentimes people equate small to less
sensitive or incapable
so in order to preserve instrument
sensitivity
many of the traditional mass
spectrometer components
had to be reconsidered and redesigned to
operate in a small form factor
the altivo was such an incredible
advancement forward for the development
of the small
form factor due to the large number of
inventions
and innovations made routine maintenance
had to be simple
so the fact shield was first developed
on this platform
a traditional octopus ion guide is too
large
so instead the cyclone ion guide a
twisted and tapered
hexadodecopol was invented
the traditional two centimeter rf only
brew baker pre-filters
are too large so instead one millimeter
dc only virtual pre and post filters
were developed instead
the quadrupoles had to be shrunk which
is a major manufacturing challenge on
its own
and lastly the vortex collision cell was
based
on the cyclone ion guide design to
maximize iron recollection
after fragmentation and to prevent
sensitivity loss
within this small form factor
with many of these hardware innovations
included on this platform
we were recognized in 2018 as award
winners by ibo
and scientist choice
as we do so with all our instruments a
robustness test was carried out on
ultivo as well
in this case 10 000 non-stop
uninterrupted injections of pesticides
spiked in black tea
were measured surprisingly despite how
dirty the original sample was
and how dirty the source got peak area
percent rsd remained less than 10
demonstrating the instrument's
incredible robustness for routine
analysis samples
and as we push the instrument hardware
boundaries
the instrument control software did as
well
incorporated with ultivo or software
features designed
to address many of the pains users
experienced
when interfacing with the instrument
things like knowing when to carry out
instrument maintenance
routine or extensive or having the
instrument
check tuned or auto-tuned and ready to
go once users come into the lab
additionally data analysis should be
comprehensive
but not complicated or complex
throughout our
whole portfolio with our data analysis
platform
we have allowed users to hone in on the
features that matter to them the most
streamlining their workflows to be as
efficient as possible
and lastly even with only three triple
quadruple lcms products within our
portfolio
the amount of hardware innovations
features and functions
is a lot to take in instead you can rely
on
agilent to be a partner for your success
as we also
aid in solving user problems through our
end-to-end
comprehensive workflow solutions these
kits contain all the necessary materials
needed
for a successful workflow for example
this comprehensive vet drug workflow
solution we've just launched
contains everything users need to get
started
in vet drug analysis on a 6470b
or a 6495c for the analysis
of over 200 compounds
before i wrap up i just want to point
out the guiding principles
and the approach that we take when
designing our mass spectrometers
we don't want the mass spectrometer to
be just a box
but rather a component for users overall
laboratory success
so as we move into the future we're
always keeping the user's needs in mind
so as i close
i just want to wrap up and remind you
that agilent has a rounded three
product triple quadruple lcms portfolio
with the latest launch this asms reboot
for the 6470b
we strive to provide users with
instruments that are not only sensitive
but extremely robust as well
the software we provide aims to be
comprehensive
but not complicated or complex this
error requires software to be
matched with their hardware for better
instrument
intelligence and monitoring
sometimes focusing just on
instrumentation
is a lot to take in on its own not
considering sample prep
method development consumable choice etc
so we provide lcms oriented
comprehensive
workflow solutions such as the vet drug
analysis
solution
and lastly we're always sticking our ear
to the ground
regarding user feedback because we want
future development to be driven
by addressing real user pain points and
needs
and keeping up with their ever evolving
and changing
requirements with that i'd like to thank
you for listening
and if you're interested in any of these
solutions please check out
agilent.com
thank you dr patoon for the outstanding
presentation
we will now move to the live q a portion
of the presentation and as a reminder
please submit your questions via the q a
box
okay let's take a look i believe we
already have
some questions coming in
dr barton when is the b model available
uh okay well i've launched or i've
announced the b
model in this presentation but this
launch was
actually not just or this announcement
was not actually
just an announcement but that same month
we launched it
so it's it's ready and available to
purchase now
so whenever you're ready we've been
selling it since
june wonderful thank you
our next question is what is the
significant
what significance is idl to my workflow
and is it an important consideration
yeah absolutely um idl
or what it's actually called instrument
detection limit
is actually the sensitivity metric that
we prefer
instead of using signal to noise this is
pretty drastic
but the reason why we choose idl as
as a sensitivity measure is because it
uses
statistics taking into account the
reproducibility
of an analyte at the lowest levels that
the instrument can
detect so instead of just looking for a
little blip
and calculating the signal to noise we
try to reproduce that
and characterize that reproducibility
compared to the actual noise
so with idl you can get a good sense of
what the overall system is able to
reproducibly detect
and it is compound specific so it can be
calculated for any compound you like
so i encourage you to feel free and
reach out
or search online for instrument
detection limit it's not just an agilent
thing but
used throughout the industry and it was
it's traditionally a gcm aspect that we
we use for lcms as well
thank you so much dr bartoon and thank
you for your presentation today
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we end
this presentation tonight
sure um at agilent we're always trying
to keep our ear to the ground on what's
changing and what
what our customer concerns are
essentially
if you have any issues if you'd like to
make any comments
if you have any concerns that you'd like
to bring up feel free to reach out to
your
agilent representative or or through the
website
and we'll try to get to you as soon as
possible
i try to personally be involved in all
that so you can reach out to me and and
i'll
i'll definitely try my best to listen
wonderful thank you so much and i want
to thank our audience for this
their outstanding questions any
questions that were submitted and not
answered today by our speaker will be
addressed by
the email this presentation will be
available
on demand viewing through september 2021
and please share it with a colleague who
might be interested in this topic today
thank you again for your participation
and i hope you will join us
for the next presenter chandra mani if
you are not moving into the virtual
studio
take care be safe and until next time
bye